this episode of gamespot's holiday gift
guide is presented by best buy hello and
welcome to GameSpot's holiday gift guide
2014 i'm jeff cannata call them
Generation Y call them Millennials we
call them core gamers the tweens teens
and twenty-somethings in your life who
spend the most amount of time playing
video games we love them and we've got
five great gift ideas that are sure to
please them sunset overdrive for xbox
one is a wild mash-up of tricked-out
skate culture and zombie roasting
explosion foo it's got attitude and
irony mocking the very culture it loves
343 Industries has put together the most
comprehensive halo anthology ever for
the Xbox one it's halo master chief
collection this is a massive package all
four main line halo titles on one disc
including a brand new remastered version
of halo 2 that looks fantastic in high
definition another camp miss shooter
this holiday is far cry 4 this decidedly
M rated game for PC PlayStation and Xbox
is a dark journey into the mouth of
madness on an untamed region of the
Himalayas far cry 4 provides a uniquely
open-world shooter experience perfect
for the older end of Generation Y a
gorgeous open-world car enthusiasts
dream of a game now we're talking Forza
horizon 2 for xbox one over 200 cars a
giant gorgeous setting make this one a
great pick for Millennials anxious to
test out their skills behind the wheel
my favorite pic is the newest game in
the Dragon Age role-playing franchise
Inquisition this is a 50 hour epic set
in a gloriously rich expansive fantasy
world Inquisition gets a full next-gen
makeover on pc xbox and playstation
and retains its excellent storytelling
so there you go 5 surefire bets for
gamers who live and breathe gaming and
who have the time and energy to dive
into the coolest deepest experiences
available this holiday season thanks for
watching i'm jeff cannata let's see you
next time